I was starting to read the
psychoanalysts and I really got I really
got interested in what they had to say
partly from reading Freud because I was
really interested in his analysis of
family dynamics and of dreams but more
particularly from reading Jung and one
of the things I learned from Jung which
really has never ceased to shock me was
his see he basically made a point and
the point was that you're not master in
your own house that there are forces
that are are operating on you at an
unconscious level that determine for
example the direction of your attention
so for example you know how sometimes
you'll read something to really grip you
and then you read something else and you
like you can't even concentrate on it
and you might say well I need to
concentrate on this boring thing you
know because an exam depends on it or a
promotion and there's just no damn way
you you're reading it and your attention
Flitz all over the place and and you
know you're undisciplined and all that
but but then you have this other thing
and it just grips you like this and you
think okay well what what's doing that
it's not your will because your will
would be the thing that would allow you
to concentrate on whatever you chose to
concentrate on it's something underneath
your will that's actually directing your
attention and you could say well it's
random but of course it's not it's maybe
random if you have a serious case of
schizophrenia but and I think in some
sense that's actually the definition of
schizophrenia but it's not random if
you're a functioning human being the
thing that grips your attention and
directs it to one place or another is
something that's what's a deep instinct
it's a manifestation of what Jung called
the self which is a very interesting
idea so Jung thought there's such a cool
idea he thought that the mechanism that
directed your attention in the present
was your future self attempting to
manifest itself in the present world so
you might say well you have a potential
and that potential is what you could be
in time and in order for that potential
to manifest itself it has to be palpable
in the present and the way that instinct
for further developed manifests itself
in the present is by directing your
attention towards things that are likely
to increase your competence and further
your growth right now
and that's just an unbelievable idea you
know it's like your your potential
better self beckoning to you in the
present amazing and I really can't think
of a better explanation for it than that
that's if that's a really good
explanation but a very frightening one
because it means in some sense that
you're that something is fundamental as
your attention is more or less
controlled by processes that are so deep
that you don't have a tremendous amount
of voluntary control over them like you
can interact with the forces to some
degree but you know you're not one of
those perky creatures that can just tell
yourself what to do
life would be really easy if that's what
it was like right you'd it's time to go
to the gym three days a week two hours a
day it's like you know you're Superman
in two years you can eat properly and
you know you're not gonna drink too much
and you're not gonna take cocaine and
all of these things you just tell
yourself that and bang you quit and it's
kind of weird that it isn't that way but
it's really seriously not that way